[Music]
stay huh
hey miss Potts if you find this
recording don't feel better about this
part of the journey use the end
[Music]
just for the record being adrift in
space with zero promise of rescue is
more fun that sounds food and water ran
out four days ago
oxygen allowed out too long morning I've
been when I drift off I will dream about
you it's how I see you hi anyone home
this is Scott Lang we met a few years
ago at the airport just an old message
holy crap everybody they really dropped
the Avengers for trailers so we got to
break it down and they revealed the
title is endgame we guess that like six
months ago so I'll talk about that there
are a couple of Easter eggs and things
the characters have said in previous
movies like age of Ultron then also dr.
strange during infinity war there's a
new brand of that IMAX ticket giveaway -
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your favorite
moment from the trailer on the video
first big thing Tony Stark stuck in
outer space on a ship on his way back
from Titan recording a message on his
helmet now the reason why he thinks he's
gonna die is because he's run out of
food and he's slowly running out of
power the power unit in his helmet
probably has like enough juice so that
if someone finds him he turns it off if
someone finds him they can turn it on
they'll get that message and they can
take it back to earth if they're nice
people like whoever finds him so there
are a couple people in deep space right
now that we know are gonna show up
during Avengers 4 that could rescue him
namely Captain Marvel who's gonna be on
her way back to Planet Earth so you have
to remember the Titan is in this part of
space and Captain Marvel is probably
somewhere in Crete and scroll space
which is a little bit further away Titan
is in the black quadrant that's sort of
like where Thanos rules in outer space
so it remains to be seen whether or not
she takes a stop by to pick him up on
the way back home but in order to do
that she'd have to pick up some sort of
distress signal so either he'd have to
figure something out or if you wanted
the WTF explainer he'd have to find some
way to extend his life force using his
technology so the whole thing about Tony
Stark is that he solves unsolvable
problems he's a genius so obviously he's
gonna MacGyver
himself out of this situation but on top
of that I also think it'll mean somebody
coming back to pick him up and don't
forget that because we have ant-man
showing up outside the Avengers facility
hey you remember me we met at Germany a
while ago after he spent all of ant-man
in the wasp telling the wasp that he was
best friends with Captain America cap
needed help scat America captain cap you
can actually use the quantum realm to
travel across space-time so they could
actually either open a Bifrost using
Thor directly to him they might destroy
the ship so if Thor could somehow
pinpoint his ship and then Bifrost right
outside it so that he doesn't blow it up
whenever he lands there are a couple
different ways they could find him with
a couple different characters but part
of the intro is him speaking to the fans
in general because part of the journey
is the end like this is the end of the
first ten years of Marvel Studios the
first twenty two films so for a lot of
these characters it's meant to be their
last big movie but we know we're getting
a black widow movie we know that Thor is
probably gonna come back and guest star
in other people's movies again in the
future if they don't do a direct Thor
four right away but I love the dust'
title transition on the Marvel Studios
title to Thanos farm with the Scarecrow
of his armor from the Infinity Gauntlet
book in him walking through his farm the
ruse was actually clarified where this
planet is - so just in general dust is a
theme of the trailer they talk about the
people that were dusted in the way the
Avengers title forms at the end the logo
it's all the dust forming back into the
title and because of Captain America's
voiceover while that's happening I don't
know what we're gonna do if this doesn't
work it's basically them undusted
everyone and reforming all of humanity
but the whole idea with a nose on his
farm is that this planet the Russo said
behind the scenes they called Titan - so
it's not exactly the original Titan but
it's like he's going back to his home
planet so this is a version of what
Titan looked like but on the set of the
movie they called it Titan - when they
were developing and shooting all this
stuff the gauntlet is still charred so
I'm assuming that this isn't too long
after we see him sit down on his farm
but the Russo said that because his
chest wound had healed they implied that
some time had passed
they didn't say exactly how much time
but it wasn't like a linear progression
of him snapping everyone out of
existence then going talking to Gamora
inside the soul world of the soul gem
and then going straight to his farm you
get the black widow voice over at the
New Avengers facility with all the
surviving original Avengers not
including Iron Man who's still stuck in
outer space Captain America has shaped
his beard and come home like where are
you going cap I'm going home I love that
Bruce Banner here is looking at the
picture of ant-man because they don't
know that he's stuck in the quantum
realm we get the reveal at the end of
the trailer but you also have spider-man
Peter Parker over here too and they're
just all in grief still kind of crying
like even Captain America is crying
Thor doesn't have any voice over but it
looks like he's just completely broken
because get this heartbreaking revealed
that the Russos also teased they said
Anna showed up at the beginning of
infinity war killed half the Asgardians
to try and get the space stone from Loki
but then after he snapped everyone out
of existence another 50% of the
Asgardians were cut so he's left with
25% of the original as guardians that he
had at the end of Thor Ragnarok so yes
there's still some Asgardians with which
to create new Asgard
but he's lost most of his people and
he's lost his brother Loki so he like
he's just sitting there grumbling like
he's super pissed off and not sure what
to do they sort of hit all the beats of
the big surviving characters when
they're talking about people who have
lost someone that they care about and
nebula is thinking about Gamora in this
moment here then when Captain America
says we lost friends we lost family we
finally get the Hawkeye Ronan reveal as
Black Widow goes to Japan to find him in
full Ronan gear with a katana wiping
what looks like blood off of it right
out of the comics confirming that
Hawkeye has become Ronan because his
family was dusted because remember how
they explained during Infinity Ward then
during ant-man and the wasp is that he
and Scott Lang took the deal because
their families couldn't handle them
being on the run with Captain America's
secret Avengers so he'd hung up his bow
completely but look at him now he is
pissed off when Captain America is
talking to Black Widow here on the Quinn
jet saying that I don't know what we're
gonna do if this doesn't work he's
wearing his Winter Soldier uniform so
he's put that back on but he shaved his
beard off and I love that they have the
compass with Peggy Carter in it because
that's something from the original
Captain America movie and you
a lot of theories about how Captain
America might go out in this movie they
might find some way to bring Peggy back
around because of all the BA ORF ain't
technology and the rumors about time
travel alternate universes we're going
to be revisiting a lot of moments in
previous Avengers films then we get the
logo with all the dust being formed back
into the a like they're reforming the
Avengers 1 and the reforming half of all
life in the universe because you have to
imagine that if they're gonna fix all
the people that they've lost it's gonna
be a solution and it'll fix everything
that they anos did so the fact that
Scott Lang shows up at the end in that
funny tag implies that quantum energy
and the quantum realm is the key to
bringing everyone back but obviously
there's really no reference to Captain
Marvel anywhere in this so I wouldn't
expect to see her genuinely in a trailer
till like the next big one and that
probably a couple months away because
her movies coming out at the beginning
of March so maybe another Avengers 4
trailer right before that but if you
don't remember here are all the times
the characters have said the words
endgame in previous movies worthy
Avengers we can bust arms dealers all
the live long day but that up there
that's that's a game
[Music]
there was no other way ranking I
remember about six months ago I did a
video about that I'm like you know what
endgame would be a really cool title but
supposedly the Russos shot that down so
even though I'm not convinced that there
are a lot of fake Hulk type moments in
this trailer this all seems pretty
genuine let me know in the comments if
you think any of this footage is not
actually going to appear during Avengers
4 because it seems real even though some
of it happens right after the end of
infinity war and some of it seems like
it happens much much later like when
Scott Lang shows up so what will happen
is is we can freak out about this for
the rest of the weekend we're gonna get
a Spider Man far from home trailer
Saturday morning so I'll break that down
as soon as it drops no worries leave
your requests in the comments below
especially if you have big questions
about stuff that's in the trailer while
you wait for everything click here for
that brand new Captain Marvel trailer
and click here for the brand-new Game of
Thrones season 8 trailer thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you